10 seconds until set
we have confirmation of separation
Orion flying on its own
again the separation occurred right on
time at 11 A.M and 11 seconds Central
Time
with Orion 3200 statute miles away from
Earth
service module the European service
module has done its job
so with Orion flying on its own we're
about 18 and a half minutes away now
from the point of entry interface
where Orion will be put through its
Paces this is where the heat shield will
begin to feel
the effects of
Peak heating of 5000 degrees Fahrenheit
on the heat shield and the beginning of
two blackout periods where the plasma
around the vehicle will build up such
that it will block data and
Communications between mission control
and the spacecraft itself
Orion continues to fly smoothly on all
of its systems in excellent shape
less than 17 minutes until entry
interface
and the crew module raise burn that we
thought was not going to be needed is
being conducted just a basically a
fine-tuning of the orientation of the
angle a 16 second firing of the
thrusters
and a good burn reported 8.12 feet per
second in a change in velocity so the
raised burn was executed uh that will
further fine-tune Orion's path at the
proper Azimuth or orientation where the
heat shield is at its Optimum angle to
begin the repulsion of the heat that
will build on around the heat shield at
the time that we begin entry interface
just about 15 and a half minutes from
now
so the crew module service module
separation went off as planned the
raised maneuver was executed at 1103 and
41 seconds Central Time
again the raised maneuver was executed
Orion now flying at the proper
orientation for entry interface into the
Earth's atmosphere entry interface is
scheduled at 11 20 and 14 seconds am
Central Time at an altitude of 400 000
feet at that point Orion will be
traveling 24
464 miles an hour with a range to splash
down of
3659 statute miles
flight controllers reporting a solid
lock with the tracking and data relay
satellite system
receiving data that's being processed
through the tdrs network
just a reminder that after we pass into
the Earth's atmosphere
at the speed at which we're going and
with the temperatures expected to build
up very quickly for Peak heating around
the heat shield of Orion we will begin
the first of two blackout periods the
first of which is scheduled to begin at
11 20 and 16 seconds am Central Time and
will last about 4 minutes and 48 seconds
at that time entry guidance which has
been on stored on board
pre-programmed commanding for Orion to
continue to point its way toward the
Splashdown Zone will take over
first blackout period should end around
11 25 and 4 seconds Central Time
that will set the stage for the skip
entry basically the maneuver that will
enable Orion to dip into the Earth's
atmosphere and Skip back out of the
Earth's atmosphere and dip back into the
Earth's atmosphere like a rock A Flat
Rock on a pond
that will continue to dissipate energy
and heat on the spacecraft
and is a maneuver that data will be
gathered for to try to bring in multiple
Splashdown sites for crude missions in
the future
the second of the two blackout periods
is scheduled to begin at 11 29 and 3
seconds am central time and that will
last for about two minutes and 55-0
seconds till about 11 31 and change
that'll be the final blackout period
after which show we should lock up
solidly for the remaining eight minutes
or so until Splashdown
thank you
this is Mission Control Houston 12
minutes away from entry interface
everything is going by the book so far
here in Mission Control very quiet on
the loops entry flight director Judd
freeling and his team of flight
controllers watching carefully over
their data as they oversee the arrival
of Orion for its Splashdown site west of
Baja California
time to splash down 31 minutes
less than 11 minutes now until entry
interface
During the period of the two blackouts
and even after we are have emerged from
the second of the two blackouts Orion
through a series of pre-programmed
commands stored on board will conduct a
series of role reversals this is very
much like space shuttles conducted
during their entries back to Earth where
it will roll to the left and then back
to the right banking role reversals that
will bleed off excess energy excess
inertia and speed and control the
thermal characteristics of the vehicle
as it heads towards its subsonic point
where it will go under Mach 1 it will
go subsonic at about 11 34 and 55
seconds am Central Time some five
minutes before Splashdown
if everything goes as planned
Orion will reach an altitude of 40 000
feet at 11 35 a.m central time just
about a minute before forward Bay cover
shoot deploy Begins the series of 11
shoots three that will pull the forward
Bay cover off of the top of the crew
module
that'll be followed by the deployment of
the drug shoots and then the three large
main parachutes three orange and white
parachutes that'll be the moment we'll
be waiting for
Orion now 28 and a half minutes until
Splashdown
Orion is approaching uh
the northwest coast of Australia
27 and a half minutes until Splashdown
we're just eight minutes away from the
point at which Orion will dip into the
Earth's atmosphere and begin what
basically is a hellish entry where
temperatures around the spacecraft will
raise uh to about 5000 degrees
Fahrenheit that's half as hot as the
outer surface of the Sun
and correction Orion is actually
traveling over the South Pacific at the
moment moving from south to North
foreign
just uh seven and a half minutes until
entry interface
and this view from a camera inside the
cabin of Orion this uh doesn't look like
much at the moment but it will soon when
it shows the forward Bay covered
jettisoning and the initiation of the
parachute deployment system
entry interface less than six and a half
minutes from now
just to recap
the crew module the Orion crew module
separated from the European service
module about 14 and a half minutes ago
right on target as it was planned and a
short raised maneuver a 16 second firing
of Orion's thrusters oriented the
vehicle raising it just a tad so that
its heat shield was at the proper
orientation of the direction of travel
to begin entry interface in about five
minutes at an altitude of 4 400 000 feet
above the Earth
Orion is making its way south to North
across the Pacific Ocean
currently traveling at 23 000 miles an
hour
we're about five minutes away from
entering the first of the two blackout
periods which will last about four
minutes and 48 seconds
a journey that began with the power of
the launch of the space launch system 25
and a half days ago
about uh to reach its final minutes in
the Searing heat of re-entry where
temperatures around Orion will build up
to 5000 degrees Fahrenheit
just under four minutes until entry
interface
once again at entry interface which we
will reach about three minutes from now
Orion will be at an altitude of 400 000
feet traveling just under 25
000 miles an hour with a range to splash
down of 3659 statute miles
within seconds after reaching entry
interface we'll begin the first of the
two blackout periods that will last just
under five minutes about four minutes
and 48 seconds
and here's the ground track for Orion as
it passes uh well to the west of South
America
we're just uh one minute 44 seconds away
from entry interface moving from south
to North to its Splashdown Target West
of Baja California
just one minute away from entry
interface
and this view from the cabin camera
looking out of the upper hatch of Orion
you can see the limb of the Earth
we're going to be losing all of the data
here shortly once we enter into the
Earth's atmosphere and begin the first
of the two blackout periods
standing by for entry interface and the
first of the two blackout periods
foreign we are now in the entry phase
entry interface has begun
entry interface at 400 000 feet Orion
traveling just under 25 000 miles an
hour
we've gone into the first blackout
period this is uh a visualization
based on what should be happening at the
moment where the temperatures around the
heat shield
are reaching about 5000 degrees
Fahrenheit This Is The Moment of Truth
for Orion
we should be coming out of this first
blackout period just under four minutes
from now
Orion should be traveling about 23 326
miles an hour at the moment
range to splash down 3125 statute miles
again this is a
visualization of what should be
happening with Orion at the moment
although we are in a blackout period
that should end about three minutes and
15 seconds from now
once we emerge from this first blackout
period we'll conduct the skip entry
maneuver
that will further dissipate Heat
and energy and begin a very very
dramatic
reduction in the velocity of Orion as it
approaches its Splashdown sight
clocks here and Mission Control showing
the sequence of events Yet to Come the
first blackout period to end about two
minutes and 18 seconds from now
the second of the two blackout periods
uh would begin about six minutes from
now
for about seven minutes followed by the
jettisoning of the forward Bay cover
that will begin the sequence of the
deployment of the parachutes
first a pair of drug shoots three pilot
parachutes that will then pull three
main parachutes
to begin the final moments of Orion's
descent back to its Splashdown in the
Pacific Ocean
one minute to go until we come out of
this first blackout period
when we emerge from this first blackout
period we'll be at an altitude of 274
000 feet traveling just under 17 000
miles an hour with a range to splash
down of two thousand statute miles
standing by for a re-acquisition of
signal
and we have data from Orion Orion out of
the blackout period
flight Dynamics reports
that Orion is right on the money coming
right down the pike a good view out of
the uh
cabin camera looking out of the upper
hatch of Orion
we should be performing the skip entry
maneuver momentarily
good Communications established with
Orion
the second blackout period to begin
about two minutes from now
Orion is at the apogee of the skip entry
maneuver beginning the second in a
series of role reversals again banking
Maneuvers to bleed off excess inertia
and to dissipate heat around the
spacecraft
the start of the second blackout period
about a minute and 13 seconds from now
will come at an altitude of 270 000 feet
with Orion traveling about 16 400 miles
an hour range to splash down less than a
thousand miles
coming up on the start of the second
blackout period
we should be in that second blackout
period right now
Ryan approaching a velocity of 20 times
the speed of sound
if all goes as planned we should be out
of the blackout period with a solid lock
up on the vehicle
at 11 31 and 46 seconds am Central Time
this is Mission Control Houston the
Airborne WB 57
one of the
Airborne assets to track Orion's return
to Earth as visual acquisition of the
vehicle
we should be coming out of this second
and final blackout about 30 seconds from
now
and hilo's flying off the deck of the
USS Portland now have a visual
acquisition of Orion as well
at an altitude of 174 000 feet traveling
12 600 miles an hour range to splash
down 288 statute miles
this view on the deck of the USS
Portland
and there is a view out of the uh cabin
camera
of Orion as it continues a series of
role reversals we have data back from
the spacecraft
flight Dynamics reports Orion straight
and narrow on a true course toward its
Splashdown site
forward Bay covered jettisoning less
than three and a half minutes from now
150 000 feet off the ocean
Orion now traveling at Mach 10.
Orion's speed now down to Mach 6.
two minutes until forward big cover
jettisoning
Orion 100 000 feet now
the spacecraft about to go subsonic
45 seconds until forward Bay covered
jettisoning
Orion now at 50 000 feet
forward big covered jettisoning pyros
are armed
25 000 feet
trogues have been deployed
two good drug shoots reported by the
recovery team out in the Pacific
the decent rate is right on the money
Orion's velocity now down to 282 miles
an hour range to splash down one and a
half miles
ten thousand feet now
and we're on mains
five thousand feet
reefing in progress
three good main shoots for Orion
we have three fully inflated main shoots
time to splash down 90 seconds
perfect descent rate reported
and there it is high over the Pacific
America's new Ticket to Ride To the Moon
and Beyond now in view
Orion under its shoots descending
towards Splashdown
Orion in the perfect orientation for
Splashdown just seconds away
one thousand feet
good decent rate
500 feet
splash down
from Tranquility base to Taurus litro to
the Tranquil Waters of the Pacific the
latest chapter of NASA's Journey to the
moon comes to a close Orion back on
Earth
unofficial Splashdown time 11 40
and 30 seconds am Central Time
at a mission elapsed time of 25 days 10
hours 54 minutes 50 seconds that's
unofficial splashing down
off the coast of Baja California
the crew module up riding system now
being inflated for
for the bags currently being inflated
and we have a report that Orion is
stable one upright the way it should be
once again Splashdown occurring at 11 40
a.m Central Time 9 40 a.m Pacific Time
west of Baja California after a textbook
entry for the Orion spacecraft bringing
its 25 and a half day mission to an end
Orion's recovery Beacon is on we have
confirmation that four out of the five
accrue module operating system bags have
fully inflated standing by for word on
the fifth one
but Orion is in great shape
stable one just in the orientation that
had been expected
this is Mission Control Houston once
again the Orion spacecraft
having completed a journey of 1.4
million miles
bobbing gently in the Pacific Ocean
four out of its five crew module
operating system bags have been deployed
we're standing by for word on the fifth
however
irrespectful of that it is in stable one
configuration in good shape according to
the recovery team
and we are now receiving word that all
five of the crew module operating system
bags are fully inflated so that's
exactly what we had hoped for
Orion safely bobbing up and down in the
Pacific Ocean
this is Mission Control Houston uh
you're looking at the Orion spacecraft
that splashed down about six and a half
minutes ago at 11 40 a.m Central Time 9
40 a.m Pacific time
we are estimating that it splashed down
around five nautical miles away from the
USS Portland
the uh recovery ship
and Navy boats and divers will be
approaching the vehicle before long
the spacecraft is in what is called a
stable one configuration upright
just the way we had expected it to be
five uh perfectly inflated crew module
uprighting system bags maintaining a
nice gentle configuration for Orion
first of the Navy helicopters now
approaching the vehicle
and here in Mission Control some of
Orion's systems no longer needed are
being powered down many of them will
stay powered up for the next two hours
while we conduct a series of test
objectives
to characterize the thermal conditioning
of the spacecraft that will be important
for future data for crude missions to
determine how long the crews can remain
comfortable inside a vehicle returning
from the Moon
we also will be conducting tests of the
Beacon and
sarsat system
for maintaining uh tracking of the
spacecraft
for Recovery forces that will be
approaching the spacecraft in the future
and uh coming up in the next hour and a
half will be the reactivation of an
ammonia boiler system that will provide
Cooling in the spacecraft as it will
when Crews return from their missions on
board Orion
this is Mission Control Houston reports
from the USS Portland indicate that the
first of two Navy helicopters uh flying
in the vicinity of Orion which is about
five nautical miles away from the ship
indicate no damage to the spacecraft and
no hazardous fuel leaking from the
spacecraft good view of the helicopters
and the initial uh Navy boats that will
be approaching Orion a short time from
now
once again the Splashdown occurring at
11 40 a.m Central Time 9 40 a.m Pacific
time
this is Mission Control Houston Orion
in the Pacific Ocean
having splashed down at 11 40 a.m
Central Time 9 40 a.m Pacific time
around five nautical miles or so from
the USS Portland
textbook entry for the vehicle
on the USS Portland at this hour my
colleague Daryl nail from the Kennedy
Space Center who's with the exploration
ground systems recovery team
Daryl uh how did it look to you it
certainly looked textbook to us here
I'd say that's a great a great
description Rob uh perfectly landed here
in the Pacific Ocean and that's been
confirmed by the operations manager that
I just spoke to
watching it from the deck as an observer
we have you know as you can see some
broken clouds in the sky like right
around 3000 feet
but uh we saw those three full main
parachutes pop out
it was a beautiful sight probably just
about
you know several thousand feet in the
sky and then we watched that slow
descent
as the Orion crew module made its way
down
to the Pacific Ocean saw the splash
and then uh of course the assets aboard
the USS Portland here immediately
started making their way towards the
Splashdown site and as you see live now
they uh they are close to being
next to the capsule now the helicopters
that you see flying there those are
inmates mh-60s
we have two of them in the air and they
are right now
Gathering
high quality high definition imagery
of the capsule in the water
there's a spot or a board we have
photographers as well
the doors are completely open on both
sides of the helicopters and so you can
see them flying
a circular track around the Splashdown
location they have marked if you can see
it you can see what looks like smoke
coming off
a location just to the left there that
is
the boats having marked location where
some of the debris has come down the
debris that was part of the separation
event the part of the parachutes opening
event
so you have
the Sabo as well as the lid from the
parachutes all of that is being tracked
by the Sasquatch team
and the Navy boats are marking that with
uh
floatable smoke grenades
all of that Hardware the team wants to
recover because there's valuable
information in data
in it
the helicopters will be out
for another 20 minutes Gathering imagery
you can see
one of them
getting very close
to the crew module
there is an GSS camera
ultra high definition 8K
which is a gathering imagery
we are currently on course
to go right by the Splashdown location
so we are right about three and a half
miles and closing
we are going to a point that's going to
be one mile out that's our next Waypoint
one mile out from the Splashdown
location
one of the things we're waiting for is
for ammonia boil off and that's why the
Navy boats are not yet next to the
capsule will still
going to wait that out the amount of
time that that's going to take is uh
has not been determined they have
allowed for as much as two hours
the ammonia on the capsule is used for
cooling purposes to keep the cabin cool
for crew of course there's no crew in
this capsule but uh
for future missions it will certainly be
an important part of keeping the
astronauts
cool
during the heat of re-entry but for now
they're going to vent off that ammonia
and as they do that it's not quite safe
to get close to the capsule with the
Navy divers
so of course we'll keep our eyes
fixed to the location
our cameras as well
USS Portland's uh standing by for our
next Waypoint one mile from
the Splashdown site
and then once the completion of the
ammonia boil off the Navy boats will be
going in
spectacular site from out here Rob toss
it back to you
thanks Daryl back here in mission
control of the entry flight director
Judd freiling on the left to his left
flight director Rick henfling
and with me on Console here probably uh
none more important than the NASA
administrator Bill Nelson Senator thank
you for joining us today
Rob I'm overwhelmed uh you know I'd say
it's good to see you but this is uh an
extraordinary day
I remember years ago when I saw you
return on Colombia from your mission
into space and it all conjures up a
tremendous amount of memories
Orion back on Earth having
circumnavigated the moon having survived
a critical test of its heat shield
you I think you have to be hesitant to
celebrate and throw confetti a little
bit too early but uh it certainly uh is
an important in treatment is it not
uh it's historic because we are now
going back into space into deep space
with a new generation
uh Kennedy uh just uh stunned everybody
with the Apollo generation and said that
we were going to achieve what we thought
was impossible
uh and did that in a short period of
time and many things have happened since
but we knew we were going back
but we knew we were going back to the
Moon just to continue to explore outward
into the cosmos
and so that's why this is a defining day
it is one that marks new technology a
whole new breed of astronaut
uh a a vision for the future that
captures
the DNA of particularly Americans
although we do this as an international
Venture and that DNA is we are
adventurers we are explorers
we always have a frontier
and that Frontier is now to continue
exploring the heavens
we had to wait a while for Artemis to
finally get to the point where the space
launch system got us underway back on
November 16th but once it did these
engineers and the other members of the
teams front room back room
they've been pretty giddy over the
amount of data that they've required and
how this vehicle appears to have
exceeded its expectations and its
performance
the whole vehicle uh the rocket uh the
European participation in the support
module
the spacecraft itself Orion
performing so well that they added a lot
of tests and uh lo and behold we're
going to be uh we're going to be up to
our years in data thankfully and of
course today the the two main things
that had to happen was that uh that heat
shield had to work and it did
beautifully where they can skip off the
atmosphere and bleed that speed down
from 25
000 miles an hour
and uh and then the parachutes had to
work and they did it as well
you know the engineering the design of
this Mission all the work that will go
into the next flight when a crew is on
board right to orbit the Moon uh what
does this say about NASA and the
international partner cooperation and
the partnership that ultimately takes us
not only to the moon but beyond
well it says a lot about our country
because we don't do it secretively
we do it openly and we do it with our
friends and we invite all peoples of the
Earth
uh and uh we are doing it also with
commercial partners because when we go
into orbit uh on Apollo 3
we are going to Rendezvous and dock with
a in this case SpaceX Lander
and the crew will go down to the surface
and and then we have another competition
going on now for another Lander so that
we will have two Landers
uh and again this is the the program of
going back to the Moon to learn to live
to invent to create in order to explore
Beyond
50 years ago today Gene cernan Jack
Schmidt landed their lunar module
Challenger
on Taurus litro the final lunar Landing
it only seems fitting half a century
later to the day
Orion back home
and uh what a what a fitting opportunity
that I had last night to sit with Jack
Schmidt at the astronaut dinner
and to talk to him about those
experiences uh 50 years it's a long time
but look what we have done in the
meantime the space shuttle we built the
International Space Station we brought
in commercial Partners we now go to and
from regularly the International Space
Station with cargo and crew
and here we go we've got Scouts going to
the Moon that are commercial Scouts that
land that take NASA instruments and
scientific instruments in preparing us
for The Landings of our astronauts and
so it's it's a new day A New Day Has
dawned
um an Artemis generation is taking us
there
and uh Orion continues uh to await the
arrival of the USS Portland which
shouldn't be very much longer from now
and some flight test objectives that
we'll be uh taking place over the next
couple of hours before we here in
Houston hand the vehicle over to the
Kennedy Space Center recovery team
NASA administrator Bill Nelson pleasure
to see you today and thank you so much
for being with us what a day oh it is my
great privilege
this is Mission Control Houston 26
minutes after the return of Orion from
its circumnavigation to the moon and a
splash down in the Pacific a bull's-eye
splash down just about five nautical
miles away from the USS Portland as had
been planned the Portland about to
arrive near the spacecraft as you heard
from Daryl nail who at this moment is
standing by on the Portland with the
woman in charge of the recovery
operations Melissa Jones Daryl
thank you rob that's right Melissa Jones
the recovery director just uh came from
outside the ship's control center where
she was monitoring and of course
managing her team in the midst of this
recovery so Melissa thank you for being
here thank you for having me it's an
exciting day what a day it is right we
just had Splashdown and want to ask you
first of all operationally where do we
stand and what do we have to go
so we had a picture perfect Splashdown
and at this time we're Gathering data
but the CM powered up we'll get some
flight test objective data on thermal
conditioning and we're doing some signal
data with the Tribune beacons making
sure that we can see the beacons on the
capsules and on the astronaut suits to
prepare for Artemis too and once that
that is complete the vehicle will be
powered down by the Mission Control
Center and they'll hand that over
officially to us here locally in the
Pacific and then we will approach the
capsule and attach some lines to it and
pull it into the back of the well deck
and that's a delicate mission right
because you will be attaching lines and
through the use of Navy boats and then
also a winch inside the well deck and
Navy sailors on the lines attached to it
as well it seems like a very delicate
operation especially getting in the well
deck where waves will be sloshing around
and we've got already four to five foot
Seas out here in the Pacific correct so
it is a delicate balance to try to
control the capsule in the well-death
all the water that we have in there and
to softly land it on a cradle so that we
can capture as much data from the heat
shield as possible
now as the capsule was coming down just
briefly tell me your reaction that
moment that it's washed up so when they
called capture from the helicopters it
was the most amazing feeling it's just
been a long time coming we've been
working this mission for a while and
we've done a ton of training and every
time you do training with a mock-up
capsule you don't have any of that you
don't have parachutes you don't you know
hear it coming back to the atmosphere
the Sonic booms and all that kind of
stuff and today that actually happened
it's just amazing
and your team it's worth noting has been
out here a long time from the moment of
launch you were on Console ready to
support if something off nominal
happened unusual you're going to be able
to recover that capsule wherever it was
needed to recover so you were working
that and then stayed through
Thanksgiving all the way to now so it's
been a long road it has been yes several
of us supported launch and then we
deployed out here about 23 days before
and we're out here for Thanksgiving as a
team so it we have been waiting for this
and preparing for it for a while
and it looks like you're doing a great
job so far good luck the rest of the way
Melissa Jones and thank you for joining
us thank you very much thanks for having
me all right Rob
thank you Daryl we'll be back to you on
the USS Portland here shortly as uh the
post Splashdown activities and the
recovery operations
will continue as mentioned earlier it
will take about two hours from the time
of Splashdown until the time that uh
flight director Judd frieling and his
team of Entry flight controllers here
will hand the vehicle over to the
exploration ground system recovery team
that will work over the next several
hours to bring the Orion into the well
deck of the USS Portland
with me a familiar face Bob Cabana
NASA's associate administrator Bob
it's great to see you here and with
Orion back on Earth another Milestone
accomplished on the road back to putting
Americans on the surface of the Moon in
terms of the criticality of what we've
seen over the past four weeks your
thoughts on how this Mission evolved and
now the stepping stone that would put a
crew on board a couple of years from now
oh rabbit's been absolutely critical uh
to get this Mission off safely uh this
test flight is what we need in order to
prove this vehicle so that we can fly
with a crew and that's the next step and
I can't wait
um you know the launch first uh yeah I
was uh on the roof with the launch
control center I went up there with the
administrator and Deputy Administrator
when we came out of the T-minus 10
minute hold and it was phenomenal it was
absolutely amazing the rocket performed
flawlessly and I haven't been that happy
in a long time after we came down off
the roof and then to see the mission go
as well as it did the shots that we got
from the vehicle that one from 40 000
miles away where you saw the the moon
with the Earth in the background and
then this morning I mean we've learned
how to operate this vehicle a few minor
glitches along the way but it is
performed uh flawlessly and we're
learning how to work with it operate it
and that's what this JSC team does it is
so great to be back here in Mission
Control to be with the Ops Team I'm so
proud of these guys amazing but if you
were watching this morning I love the
video I don't know if it was on NASA TV
or not but the moon just kept I mean the
Earth just kept getting bigger and
bigger it was really hauling as it came
in and the preciseness with which they
were able to bring it down and seeing
the shoots come out and it's just I I'm
so proud of this team the Orion team the
entire SLS Artemis team the folks here
at JSC it's just been amazing now my
only I wish Gene cernan were still alive
you know here we are on the 50th
anniversary and Gene was such a
proponent of getting us back to the Moon
I wish I wish you were alive to have
seen this Mission it would have meant a
lot to them
I don't want to date you but I think 24
years ago
write this at this moment in time you
were building a space station I believe
with your crew on sts-88 uh
we had so many dramatic jaw-dropping
images during the course of this flight
what for you was the most impactful
moment
uh I I don't I'm not sure I can pick one
obviously the launch the team has worked
so hard uh to get to the point where we
successfully launched this rocket
um I think the successful Burns along
the way to actually get that go for the
tli burn and do it and be on our way to
the Moon again
absolutely awesome I think the pictures
that we saw but the Splashdown how can
you not I mean this was really emotional
going around and congratulating folks
for what we did so I uh it's hard to
pick just one I think what has meant the
most to me
and more than just watching the mission
more than the mission highlights is
being with the teams at the Kennedy
Space Center at the Marshall space
flight center here at the Johnson Space
Center and just being able to go up and
talk to them and thank them for all
their hard work that got us to where we
are I think I just it means a lot to me
and Bob uh final question the The Next
Step Artemis 2 putting a crew on a
vehicle to orbit the Moon it's going to
be a complicated Mission it's a long
road it seems like a long time from now
but based on what we've just witnessed
and based on what we believe will be the
ultimate data flow out of this Mission
it doesn't seem that far away does it it
is not that far away it's going to mean
a lot when we get the crew assigned and
we see them in training we get that
human face to this I've seen the flight
Hardware at KSC the Orion 2 spacecraft
for Artemis 2 is there it's in build we
got to get Artemis one back and transfer
some of the black boxes across to make
sure that they get checked out and
everything works
um you know the the Rockets being built
we are on the way and it I think when
you put a human face to that when you
actually see that hey we're sending
humans to the Moon again and we're going
to get this one year Cadence eventually
where we're doing this on an annual
basis this is our future and it's it's
different from how we went during Apollo
we're going in a sustainable way we're
Paving the way to go on to Mars not just
the moon and Mars but to establish a
presence in our solar system beyond our
home planet to explore to have those
Technologies in space to continue to
learn and uh and improve things here on
planet Earth
Bob Cabana NASA's associate
administrator thanks so much for being
with us Bob rob it is always a pleasure
to share a mic with the voice of NASA
I'm uh I think a lot of you buddy you
know that we've worked together a long
time you keep doing a great job
thank you very much Bob Bob Cabana
NASA's associate administrator with us
here in Mission Control